[Musik]
das bild alle formen halbe jahrhundert /
brüssel
meine damen ständigen kirche ist es gab
zirkel der bis gratis und ich habe mich
furchtbar gelangweilt und hatten einfach
vorgeschichte filter für der römischen
legion und ich glaube das ist
geburtsstunde als autor der vor 50
jahren
wo die zeit stillzustehen scheint in
burg uhr kanton jura am äußersten rand
der schweiz hat chur nie das leben
erlernt in einer werkzeugkiste the hard
way sagt conny der harte weg
das ist die geschichte eines mannes der
früh erfuhr dass man keinen anspruch hat
auf glück und den diese erkenntnis zum
erfolg führte
[Musik]
das ist diener diener ist laut königs
zweite frau sie holt seine generation ab
seit 2009 kämpften eng betreut von
diener ums nackte überleben
33.000 bilder der 60 jährige in den
letzten jahren eingeworfen
2009 ist er an leukämie erkrankt
blutkrebs lag sechs monate auf der
isolierstation
es ist eine der vielen katastrophen in
konnys leben
doch kuranyi hat sie alle überlebt die
katastrophe er ist ein wandelndes
sprichwort was mich nicht umbringt macht
mich stärker
gornys tag beginnt früh nachts um 3 uhr
steht er auf und treibt zuerst einmal
sport
[Musik]
nun haben wir wieder mit wo es gibt
darin juglar seien dann sagen nicht dass
alles was er hat mir engstens
verschossen
wir sehen aber immer dann nach hause
beschrieben
das sind ja wir wo wird der kleinstadt
hält ich schaue testament machen als er
mir fahre quartale des jahres vorsichtig
der stärkeren einer die medikamente nach
der knochenmarktransplantation lassen
ihn überleben
dafür hatte halluzinationen natürlich
ließ sich davon nicht zu mögen und
verarbeitete die medikamenten trips in
seine zweite autobiografie pacific
avenue skript avenue war die erste 640
seiten ein bestseller
er schrieb sie im angesicht des todes
isolierstation aber immer noch leukämie
und eigentlich steht also in der
nächsten woche verbietet familie und wir
haben im sommer familie fantasiewelt
wollen skript damen jugend a nightmare
zeitschrift doch eher durch skripte
avenue und den mann jörg fange damit
kann natürlich immer denkt es überhaupt
sind das durch noch schreibe oder nicht
und ist so nett wie immer pusht dass sie
dort weiter machen und mir am schluss
780 siebter konnte namenskürzel 640 und
das hat man natürlich zielke und der
rahmen möglich bewertung schrieb
überzeugt dass ich nicht stehe bevor das
buch fertig ist ich bin natürlich
entsprechend detailliert was dürfen
fertig
juli legt noch heute obwohl man das kaum
für möglich hielt als er vor sieben
jahren mit blauen flecken aufwachte und
etwas besorgt ins spital ging behielt
man ihn gleich dort diagnose akute
lymphatische leukämie kurz prognose
schneller tot
im ersten moment wohl dann einfach
luftballon wo platz ist los mit dem
zweiten mal meint an die denkt yahoo
rasiert was machen jetzt mit dem sohn
alisher 3
und ich würde sagen dann spielt lieber
und ich an seite mit oder der heißt nach
chicken curry und denn wohl in deiner
like säbel im zimmer noch danke
dank den grund glauben historischer
vergleich bin ich trotzdem ein
glückspilz den historischen vergleich
ziehen damit sind wir in chur ließ welt
angelangt in seiner fantasie und bei
seinen büchern
cordis welt besteht das römer aus
draufgängern und ein company ist
geschichtenerzähler schreibt historische
romane in seinem kopf zumal sich helden
vagabunden und druiden sein kopfkino
nennt das skript avenue ein unendlicher
schatz an erfundenen und wahren
geschichten zwölf romane unzählige
drehbücher und theaterstücke sind daraus
bereits entstanden
[Musik]
spät abends führt der schauspieler david
bröckelmann historisch interessierte
zuschauer durch basen kitzelt aus
dunklen gassen und verlassenen ecken das
vergessene hervor
belebt die vergangenheit
[Musik]
bröckelmann macht wir touristen auf
einem stadtrundgang das was am
schreibtisch kuranyi für seine leser tut
in unserer geschichte geschichten finden
[Musik]
wir gut sonst eigentlich hinter gut wenn
man sich vorstelle verlieren als 100
sitzen der mann eingestochen von
krankheiten und der tod ist damals
altersklasse prozent findet das sterben
der steingriffer stas control mit seinen
historischen romanen ebelt coni
zuversicht in die gegenwart denn kaum
etwas dafür besser gewesen figur aber
nie saal brachten daher größer wäre
sicherer schaffe das eigene schicksal um
die recherchen für seine bücher zeigen
dem schriftsteller
das leben ist eine schlange das
schlimmste kommt unerwartet
es gibt nicht immer ein papier in dem
leben
wir müssen doch hier nicht auf einem
untergrund gegangen
man lernt was lernt bei mir gerecht ist
und muss gerecht sie gelernt dass du das
muss er akzeptieren
wohl oder übel und dass man schwere
niederlage erlitten aber dass man eben
aufstehen wenn er das macht weil man es
machen
das ist logisch coni 34 jahre alte woods
wie versuch und eine der katastrophen
die coni erhalten natürlich nicht
gläubig selbst sondern der unfall den
profis als baby erlitt ich bin danach
nach der arbeit noch einige ins
kinderspital und bayerische freie geburt
ganz oft mache ich also in ein import
aus stücks und bayerischer wald oder
abgeschafft mit sei also perfekt leben
ja schon ich sehe das ganz verkrampfte
spastisch mit glücklich erlebt
und ja auch größter schädel der bisher
basiert im brutkasten fütterte das
personal clovis hirn mit sauerstoff dumm
gelaufen er erlebt eine cerebralparese
aus einem gesunden frühchen würde
schlagartig ein spastiker er überlebte
steif wie die kinderleichen von pompeji
vor 2000 jahren in vulkanasche
konserviert wurden so beschreibt vater
coni der römer fan das unglück seines
sohnes
koni packte an was zu tun war über jahre
trainieren ehren seine erste frau den
kleinen buben täglich vier stunden
bringen dem verkrampften körper das
gehen und greifen bei ziel clovis wird
trotz schwerster behinderung ein
ungehindertes leben führen
ein großes problem ist nur dass
finanziell achse sie hat damals 100
ausgang monat verdient therapie
schobranski monaten an die vor allem
augenblick für eine untere von bäumen
modus ein workaholic modus umschalten
ihrer einer fernsehanstalt exposé
geschickt und auffordert zu serien
krimiserie wurden moment gerade der
koffer sind und das erst die
krimikomödie film calvo danken walo
lüönd und stephanie glaser gottschalk
der rekordkurs und fordert bin drai
paradoxie und haben glück verdient und
das alles finanzieren späterer um die
historische roman zu finanzieren
nach jahren des trainings kam klein
clovis seine beinprothesen nie von
papier versprochen in den abfall
schmeißen
aus dem spaß dicker der sich kaum
bewegen konnte wurde ein jurist der
heute als basler strafrichter arbeitet
wenn es wirklich will dass wir den affen
tief dass sie verfolgt und das
bestmögliche macht um das ziel der reise
und die sache war nicht so wichtig sind
dass man die in den hallen der bisher
weniger priorisiert und atme euro zeigt
dass ein nach vilshofen maschinen sind
durchaus möglich
unwahrscheinlich ist möglich machen wie
im comic kapitän haddock ist ein
prototyp für ponys figurenkabinett für
seine skript avenue alltag fällt immer
wieder auf die schnauze schafft aber
immer wieder den richtigen dreh wie
conny der will jetzt die biografie der
berühmten comic figur erfinden
disaster und komik machen das leben aus
da gibt es kein entrinnen
dafür steht auch kunis bisher
erfolgreichster roman hält john o
online glücksspieler schwinger und geld
theoretiker der am hofe von louis den 14
tatsächlich lebte und das moderne
papiergeld erfand leider auch gleich die
moderne spekulationsblase
das leben ist ein spiel der ausgang
eines einsatzes ungewiss wie john law
ist auch kuoni ein getriebener
und als er den stoff rund um den
draufgänger tumor entdeckt gibt es kein
halten mehr
der schwerenöter und genialen
zahlenmenschen lausitz toni mit seinem
roman der große spieler ein denkmal
da hat mir immer gestärkt und sieht als
ursache
und ich glaube das ist genau der grund
wieso so viele leserinnen und leser
treppe hand dass durch siege nur machen
es gibt eine schwierige aber lösbare
sache altbacken
[Musik]
selbe spielt kuranyi nicht aber mit dem
roman über einen spieler landete einen
volltreffer in zwölf sprachen gibt denn
laut zu lesen wenn bestseller top goalie
noch mit eigenen computer games
entwickelt in den 90er jahren komplexe
auf seinen geschichten basierende
computerspiele das schicksal dem coni
ist es mehrmals brutal in die knochen
gefahren
schauspieler david bröckelmann
langjähriger freund hat dazu eine eigene
theorie vielleicht sechs schicksale eine
gewisse stabilität an weil erfolge
bleibe haben wo der satellit könne
anders verarbeiten und das ist eine
unserer vorliegen das könne stelle wo
halt nicht einfach nur gültig sind und
schön
wie john law stürzte auch kuoni vom
glück ins unglück zurück als er endlich
vom geschichtenerzählen leben kann und
sein sohn sich prächtig entwickelt
der krebstod ein ball ins lebensglück
und im garten verbrannt was ist für sie
so wenn er sehr persönliche schlappe
zeremonie auxilion abschieds von der
welt
[Musik]
marie marie balkon ist große liebe
seine erste frau in den 70er jahren
haben sie sich kennengelernt
hier auf der schanze des basler münsters
er habe seine frau auf basels plattform
für selbstmörder angesprochen stellt
coni in seiner autobiografie zweideutig
fest und beschreibt die erste begegnung
mit der späteren mutter seines sohnes so
sie trug einen schwarzen kapuzen man wie
die nachtwächter im mittelalter trotz
der späten stunde schild sie keine angst
vor mir zu haben
ich setzte mich neben sie vielleicht hat
es die lust sich in das skript avenue
einzumieten
da sich in den 70er jahren gesehen zwei
jahre dort und breit keine venture qre
und sind mindestens elf stand dann bei
nand gesagt sehr ohne ortswechsel und
dann kann dieser spontan gefragt ob sie
mehrere geschichte erzählt doch fluss
sagte sie leise ist derweil lehrmeister
des lebens alles fließt nichts bleibt
stehen
du kannst einfluss nicht festhalten das
wasser zerrinnt in deinen händen so ist
das leben du bist nichts als ein
bedeutungsloser tropfen in einem fluss
und dann ende hat auch der fluss keine
bedeutung mehr
[Musik]
was 30 jahre konnten claude und al amri
zusammensein flossen gemeinsam im strom
des lebens
dann teilte der krebs ihre gemeinsamkeit
auf leben und tod
das figurenkabinett skript avenue mischt
er annemarie als fordernder charakter
auf sie meinte anrecht zu haben auf ein
faires schicksal haderte oft mit der
unbill des lebens
aber gerechtigkeit im leben ist wenig
mehr als purer zufall
ja ich bin letzte tag vor ihrem tod hat
sie akzeptiert dass sie schafe wird und
sie hat sich alfred schlosser und
herzlich bedankt für die lange pflege
und sie stellen die bienen und nimmt
eine antwort so ungestört schrank lehrt
und der schrank offen
damit man jeden tag dass kein mensch
etwas besonderes ist das einem im leben
nichts geschenkt wird das sitzt tief
drin im klotener
so sieht er die welt so ist ihm das
leben begegnet nun nachdem fast tod
seines sohnes und dem langsamen sterben
seiner ersten frau nun ist die täglich
mit der eigenen vergänglichkeit
konfrontiert der krebs kann schnell
zurückkommen er aber der immer
entschlossen einen ausweg nimmt sieht
auch in den schicksalsschlägen das
positive
beschissene biografie seine eltern sind
eine erste begegnung mit katastrophen
der vater überfordert vom leben erzählt
claude mit scharfer hand und kunis
mutter eine katholische taliban nicht
einfach streng religiös sondern
wahnwitzig gläubig treibt den buben die
faxen mit weihwasser aus
die fundamental indoktrination trieb
klein claude in die flucht ins kino zu
den western helden zu comic helden zu
rittern und römern skript avenue die
fantasie als letzter ort in einer welt
die sonst wenig zu bieten hatte im
jurassischen bank uhr also hat gott coni
sich ans leben herangetastet
heute hat er zum ort keinen bezug mehr
will keinen haben dass er als baby oft
in einer werkzeugkiste abgestellt wurde
ist nur noch anekdote
seit jahrzehnten war nicht mehr in jeder
kirche wo die bilder der
leidensgeschichte christi seine
unerschöpfliche phantasie geweckt hatten
kurney aber ist überzeugter atheist
religionen sind ihm ein gräuel von
religion in form von aberglaube aber es
soll jeder körper wasser wort und der
wand damit in alu wir haben die nummer
mit den religiösen fundamentalisten da
gibt es sowohl in der muslimischen welt
als auch hinter christoph lütgert einem
einzelsitz laber hand und sich ab sofort
voll tisch richter zu alt ihnen noch zu
gunsten von angeschrieben hand und wenn
er mal da ungemein bild ich kann frau
heutiger bremer auch schüler fanatismus
das ist thema von coolness neuestem
roman kein historischer sondern einer
der in die zukunft schaut
es geht um islamismus ich glaub gene
ströme da dürfen wir keine toleranz
entgegen bringen
die toleranz reformfähigkeit nicht
glaubt was man nicht verteidigt der
verliert und unsere freiheitsrechte
nicht verhandelbar
[Musik]
und wie geht claude kuranyis
lebensgeschichte weiter hat das
schicksal eine weitere ohrfeige für ihn
parat oder wieder mal glück in hongkong
lebten collins sein sollen 2008 09 nach
dem tod von annemarie wollten sie neues
glück ermöglichen
und ja in hongkong lernte coni seine
heutige frau diener kennen die nah kam
in die schweiz und ins unglück kunis
leukämie brach aus dina konnte claude
der mann soll ihr zimmer lag nur noch zu
winken
wenn das leben eine achterbahn ist
claude coni sitzt im vordersten wagen
er weiß worauf schlussendlich ankommt
einziger wirklich zählt ist das wofür
anderen gemacht
dazu biete das 1 3 liter besseres jahr
bei hand und das ist als wohlüberlegt
natürlich reine divx willen alles hätte
verfalldatum
[Musik]